MIKE: We're at Bobby's
And after looking at
his 1967 Jaguar XKE,
and we get back to
the 36 Knuckle engine.
The serial number on
this side is incredible.
You know, obviously, this one
being the low serial number,
and then the belly
number as well.
The other side of the case--
this is the issue with it here.
So what I know so far is,
it's got a later oil pump,
the heads are
correct, but they need
work, the cylinders are wrong,
the belly numbers don't match.
I'm taking all of this
into consideration
with trying to gauge
the value of this thing.
The way it sits right now
with what you have that's
correct and incorrect,
I'd do $15,000.
I don't know about 15.
What's your-- what's
your bottom on it?
I guess, bottom, we go 18,500.
What do you think?
With everything wrong with
this engine, the one thing
that's right is that it's '36.
It's first year.
And that's what I'm
hanging my hat on.
And it's a big deal that
Bobby put a number on it.
If everything goes right,
you know-- because I mean,
it needs the correct
push rod tubes.
It needs the correct cylinders.
I mean, there's things to
acquire to build the engine.
But once you get the things
to build the engine, I mean,
it's going to cost 7,000
bucks to build the engine.
Right.
MIKE: I know what it's going
to cost to build this engine
and to get the correct parts.
First engine.
No, I know.
It's not the very-- man,
just think that it was 1001.
Yeah, I know.
Well, what is it--
two something?
MIKE: It's 229.
I'm hypnotized by this thing.
I don't want to leave it.
I really feel like, if you've
got a fork, maybe some fenders,
and you've got an
engine, you can
probably start building a bike.
I want to treat you the
way I would want someone
to treat me with my stuff.
Because when I'm gone, you
know, I'm going to have a lot
of stuff too, laying around.
And somebody's going to
buy stuff off my family.
I'd do 17 grand on it.
Well, if you give me 17,5000
now, you can walk away with it.
I'm going to do it.
It ain't like you
see them everyday.
I love the low serial number.
I love the history of
it with your family.
Your dad was smart
to pick it up.
He was smart to keep
it all these years.
And--
- Stashed in the basement.
--it's obvious,
looking around here--
BOBBY: Stashed in the basement.
MIKE: --that he understood it.
He understood all of it.
Yeah, live to ride.
MIKE: Well, it's going to
be back on the road again.
I can guarantee you that.
I seen his eyes light up.
I knew that.
That's the one
everybody's always after.
So I'm glad to see that
it went someplace good.
Let's carry it out.
You got that side?
[grunts]
- I'll clear your way.
MIKE: I think Bobby
knows that I'm
the guy that's going to get this
back on the road just the way
his father--
[cash register dings]
--would have wanted.
- All right.
You got it?
- [inaudible]
Treat them like
it's a little baby.
I think my dad's
happy that the motor's
going to be back out there.
I feel good about it.
Hey, man.
We got there.
Appreciate you.
Hey.
I love talking to guys
that are into motorcycles
as much as I am, especially
when it's generational.
God bless you guys.
All right.
Thank you.
- Take care.
All right.
Be good now.
See you on the road.
The old man had that big of an
impact on Bobby and his son.
And it's cool to hear
them talk about him
and to see them be in that
space with those bikes.
Because now, it's
their real estate.
It's their time.
[horn honks]
Roll on!
BOBBY: All right.